I wanted to start off by saying have you
figured out how to say Phuket Phuket
because I still don't even know how to
say right well I learned before going
actually because I would say before
knowing Phuket and it's actually
pronounced with the p so it sounds like
a p so it's like Phuket ah okay see you
every day
but I think we were all confused at that
point like we didn't even want to say
where we were we were like oh but we
would just say Thailand
so why did you decide to go on this all
Girls All-Star trip
why because first of all I I think that
it's kind of like the house life
Olympics that it's kind of like if you
make it there it's like it's something
like that you want to do yeah and you
know the fact that I got to go with um
you know my best friend and you know
Miami coming back on TV and having such
a strong comeback and then being you
know selective for this was like an
honor and then the other franchises as
well Potomac Salt Lake City you know
Porsche I was going from Atlanta from
New York I just thought it was a great
group of girls and and you know a
wonderful opportunity and I was very
excited about it with was there a
housewife that you were most anxious
about meeting
you know I was excited and anxious to
meet all of them honestly I knew Giselle
I knew of Porsche I was
um I I had this idea of like Heather and
Whitney that I would be like best
friends with them because I liked like
who they were and I saw them like as
happy people you know I hadn't watched
obviously they had just wrapped up their
last season so I was not aware this is
what happens and a lot of people don't
realize that so Potomac Salt Lake City
and Miami we had just literally wrapped
up our last season right so you and I at
least in my case for Miami like 10 days
later I was packing my bags and leaving
to Thailand so I we really didn't get
that rest you know in between and then a
lot of the girls bring carry over and
transfer that whatever it wasn't
resolved on their season on to the
ultimate girls trip
so that's where you'll be seeing a
little bit of that and I think that that
really applies to all of us and all that
uh like the Gen Sean news kind of just
had broke right when you guys were
leaving like what was that correct yeah
so Heather I think came from New York
you have had just finished here in New
York I happened to be in New York now
that's why I'm saying New York
um so uh so she had just left New York
and I think and that's when all that was
going on and from there she went to
Thailand so she knew I'm sure when she
got there you know Giselle was really
good at starting to question what all
that was about
yes she was yeah but I mean how can you
not honestly you know I mean I like
Heather but it was kind of like okay
like she's your friend so you have to
come and like we felt like you know
we're on a girls trip we have like you
know seven eight days you know to get to
know each other and what do you do you
ask questions of course of course and
what was it like obviously it must have
been great having Marisol there having
your best friend there
absolutely yeah so we I always felt like
we had that Advantage because you know
we were such good friends and um and we
were staying together
but with that being said you know even
though you have a best friend and you
love her and adore her after 13 days and
also wrapping up the season like I said
that some things weren't resolved it
kind of transfers over into the ultimate
girls trip
so I was like the day 13 I was like
update here I was like oh my God I can't
wait to go home and go back to my bed
and my privacy and the whole thing so
you know you'll see like a little bit of
that but you know at the end it's all
good because you know we we fight like
sisters we love each other like sisters
and and that's what we do
and so what we've seen so far there was
like a little bit of drama over the
Spanglish of you guys speaking
I know
and it's so funny I never expected that
so I was just telling one of the other
journalists I spoke to before that since
I was hosting like a Miami yacht party
and you know all these girls you know I
probably are seeing my show and they're
probably saying oh they speak like
Spanish and English and in Spanish and
whatnot I had brought like a little game
to teach them Spanish without even
knowing that Giselle was gonna say that
day one
but she was quick you know to say you
know to explain which is you know always
what I like to do like give you the
opportunity I mean there has to be
something there you're just not going to
say something like that so when she did
you know I was good with it and for like
whatever reason you know I've always
like liked Giselle you know I think that
that has you know a lot to do with it I
really never watched these shows before
so I didn't want to know who they were
like on their shows
I wanted to give them like you know an
opportunity to get to know them for who
they were yeah for real like that's how
I did like of course I knew things that
I've watched but I'm not like the
consistent type like that because I
really don't watch too much TV I don't
have time sometimes while I'm watching
these shows it gives me anxiety because
I know what they're feeling because I'm
part of this so I said no matter what we
all have like this bond together right
because we you know did this journey you
know we're all a little bit crazy and
that's what I want this show so it's
kind of like we all get each other and
we really don't have any backstory
because we don't really have had any
like beef like from before so there's
nothing really to like hash out so let's
just you know start you know from from
fresh and you know and just get to know
each other and that's what I did and and
it worked for me I mean I truly liked
all of them
and had a great time with all of them
and you were so open about your personal
life
um and then when Leah kind of set at
that dinner that it was boring like how
did that affect you right well Lee I was
being Leo I was I figured out Leo like
day one I was like okay you're a Debbie
Downer like you want to get you you want
to read it for everybody I'm the
opposite if I were her I would have gone
there and I would have said okay I'm the
only one here that's by myself I'm not
on TV right now but I have this amazing
opportunity and I'm gonna get to meet
all these women that do the same thing I
do by the way or that she did and have a
blast and have fun I would have been
friends with all of them like which is
like what I was trying to do you know
like I said if I would have got a loan
my Dynamics maybe with the group would
have been a little different but because
I went with Marisol was a lot of Marisol
and I but if not I go by myself and I'm
super friendly and I would have been
best friends with all of them so it did
surprise me that she came with that
attitude kind of right like I don't want
to be there it was kind of like that's
what she was saying I don't know what
I'm doing here like so that there like
kind of like turned me off a little bit
because you know I didn't think that
that was right like how do you do that
you know and what's so bad about this I
mean this is like beautiful you're in a
beautiful country you're like with all
these amazing women that we all do the
same there's one way or the other she
could relate to all of us because you
know we're all women you know we've done
the same thing we're mothers we're
daughters we're sisters so it's like you
know focus on the positive
so this might you might have already
answered this question which of the
housewives would you never want to go on
a vacation with again you know I don't
like to say never but you know because I
I want to believe that there's something
that she does have like a fun side to
her that maybe like Candace got to see
or Heather or Whitney I'm not sure who
but them
and um so I would like to bring it out
on her I would I would like to so I I
definitely would go back with the entire
group and I think that you know that
there is that fun side to her that for
whatever reason you know she didn't want
to show us so I actually have to go on
another trip over there because I want
to see the upside to her
if you could build your Dreamcast for
the next uh girls trip what would it be
or who would be on it oh that's a great
that's a great question
um so for sure Marisol uh because I need
her to make the cockies for all of us
and yeah and um all the cockies yes even
though we all drink I know she's the one
that gets like all the thing but we all
drink the same but I would love to do it
with like Teresa Kenya
Cynthia
I mean there's so many like
extraordinary women like on all these
shows that I've gone to know and I think
they all bring something different
um
but yeah there's like just like a few
Porsche I loved and Giselle
and and there's just so many of them
honestly there was really a lot I think
that the cast would have to be a lot
larger because I would have to
definitely pick more than eight messiest
housewife oh that's a tie there was so
many of them uh I could say
uh Giselle
okay like messy yeah who came in second
I want to say
it could be Candace and Leah yeah I mean
I don't know like I know like in the
housewife world how we refer to Messi
was like a little different
um so I have to see you know but
I feel like we can all be a little messy
when it's necessary totally okay
um most dramatic housewife
like major drama even though Candice is
a little theatrical yeah but um I want
to say like dramatic at that point would
be Leo
okay um best dressed housewife
you know I I loved
I think all of us really like brought
the fashion and you know we all wear it
like differently yeah but you know I
loved it like
um Porsche I loved Porsche's wardrobe I
loved Whitney's I loved Candace's I
loved Heather's
um you know Marisol has a different
style but it's like so beautiful and
elegant so you know I thought that we
all brought it even though it was super
hot and we're like we literally didn't
even know what to wear how hot it was
so even when you landed you said that
yes it was and I'm used to Miami but it
was like it was honestly we we have that
Advantage also Marathon I was so used to
that kind of climate but still it was
really unbearable yeah but I thought it
was in general I've been dying yes well
look out yeah Heather from Imagine Salt
Lake City that they're used to like cold
all the time she was like I thought she
was the one that's gonna pass out not
Leah
um okay we're stress housewife
I'm not going to say Giselle because I
know that's what you guys want me to say
because she dresses nice it's just like
and she does and she had like pretty
things you know she doesn't know she
just doesn't know
um like how beautiful she is and how
sexy she can be you know she's like
that's how she dresses but like I could
dress her like in one of my dresses and
she'll look and I mean she's beautiful
to begin with so it's not like the
clothes that finds you but
she's I think she's like getting it now
I think like after like this trip and
whatever and you know they'll be like oh
okay you know like she can wear whatever
she wants to wear because she's
beautiful but I thought honestly
there were we were all well-dressed yeah
and even Leah with the little clothes
that she wore yeah you know it was like
cute you know what I mean it was like it
made sense it was like sexy so I thought
we we all wore like really nice outfits
okay and last question other than
Marisol of course who um from the girls
trip what do you think would most likely
be your next BFF
hmm
you know I'm thinking like I've done
press with Giselle I like Giselle a lot
I like Giselle a lot and I like poor
Charlotte and Heather I think that those
are the three I was in Salt Lake City
actually Whitney too like I reached out
to Whitney and Whitney right away we're
all trying to get together but then
there was a blizzard
um we have a snow blizzard so we did it
but you know we'll communicate but um
and even Candace honestly I liked all of
them but I think the most the ones that
I've like kept in touch with the most
because of the circumstances or just
because we like each other has been like
Giselle and Porsche we have like a group
text so we're like you know texting and
we keep in touch but honestly they're
all like fabulous women